[Music]
you're enjoying a nice day on an ocean
cruise you're relaxed and secure
too bad that a rogue wave human error
high winds or a mechanical failure just
ruined your trip suddenly a huge spray
of water douses your clothes people are
rushing around shrieking and falling
over deck chairs the floor underneath
your feet is lurching your ship is
sinking so how do you survive here's how
to withstand the danger of a sinking
ship according to science long before a
potential disaster strike there are
steps you can take in order to be
prepared
first up listen before a ship sails very
far the captain or a crew member will
give a safety briefing over the speakers
as boring as that may be it will prepare
you and maybe even save your life
find where your life jacket is and
practice putting it on because it may
restrict your movement when it's on
don't wear it just carry it with you
during an emergency and put it on when
you're on the deck always have your
important medication with you in case
your ship does sink and you're on a
lifeboat for several weeks next take a
walk make a mental note of the signage
the stairwells and especially the exits
in case of smoke and feeding your sight
you need to have an idea of where
everything is during an emergency
disaster strikes now do the same thing
you did earlier listen the crew is
trained for emergencies so if
instructions are being issued follow
them try to breathe from your stomach
instead of your chest to stay calm
most importantly do not panic according
to studies 70% of people experience
lessened reasoning ability when they
panic and you don't want to be one of
them if you're on the lower section of
the ship get up toward the deck stay on
the ship for as long as you can as it's
your safest bet avoid jumping into the
water as that's the most dangerous
option
did you feel a big lurch do you see
water where it shouldn't be
listen for your captain to announce
abandoned ship and watch for the crew to
drop lifeboats into the water now for
the surprising news if you're a woman or
a child and you're expecting polite
behavior from your fellow passengers
don't count on it everyone's in a panic
and there are no actual maritime laws
requiring that women and children get on
lifeboats first when a crew member helps
you into a lifeboat stay calm when
you're out at sea collect rainwater in
any containers you have do not drink
seawater or urine people with determined
and positive attitudes are the ones who
tend to survive distract yourself from
the cold and other discomfort by playing
mental games counting and thinking of
others if you can try to tie your
lifeboat to other lifeboats ideally all
the lifeboats will be tied together so
that everyone is easier to find and
rescue your best chance of survival now
is to be helpful and friendly to your
fellow survivors share your water food
and good morale it'll be difficult and
scary but if you follow these
instructions you have a good chance of
surviving a sinking ship according to
science